SECRETARY WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO. GIL. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD. CABALLERO
CORTEZ. DALLEY. DODD. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. GLASER. GONZALEZ. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD. LIMON
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. ROTH. RUBIO. SATO
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN UMBERG. WAHAB. WIENER.
WILK MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WHAT? OUR MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS. BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY. PLEASE RISE.
WE'LL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR BECKER.
AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING TO ASK
YOU TO REMAIN STANDING FOR THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. SENATOR BECKER. MERCIFUL
AND MYSTERIOUS GOD, YOU WHO
NEVER CEASED TO PRACTICE THE ART
OF CREATING. KEEP US EVER AT THE
EDGE OF OUR SKILLS, OUR HABITS,
OUR VISION THAT WE MAY NEVER
GROW. SO CONTENT IN OUR CREATING
THAT WE MISS YOUR PRESENCE. YOU
WHO ARE EVER ABOUT TO DO A NEW
THING IN OUR WORLD. WE ASK THIS
IN YOUR NAME. AMEN MEMBERS. NOW
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE.
SENATE RESOLUTION 94 BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE. RELATIVE TO ANIMALS.
SENATOR MCGUIRE, THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES, I RISE TODAY FOR A
CAUSE THAT'S WARM AND FUZZY, AND
THAT'S GOING TO LEAVE YOU
HOWLING WITH EXCITEMENT. SR 94
IS GOING TO PROCLAIM JUNE 1ST OF
CALIFORNIA ADOPT A PET DAY. NOW
IT'S VERY PERSONAL FOR ME. THIS
IS EXTRA PERSONAL BECAUSE MY
MOM, MY MOM, HAS BEEN A LIFELONG
FOSTER MOM FOR CATS AND DOGS AT
OUR LOCAL SHELTER. IN FACT, GREW
UP WITH LITTERS OF CATS AND
PUPPIES AND DOGS. MY ENTIRE
LIFE, AND THEY CONTINUE TO BE AT
OUR HOUSE. AND WHILE LOCAL
SHELTERS SAW GREAT INCREASES IN
ADOPTIONS DURING THE PANDEMIC,
THOSE ADOPTION RATES HAVE NOW
SLOWED IN MANY AREAS OF OUR
STATE. SHELTERS ARE OVERCROWDED,
AND TO HELP EASE THIS
OVERCROWDING, TO PROVIDE SOME OF
THESE AMAZING FUR BABIES A
FOREVER HOME, THE CALIFORNIA
ANIMAL WELFARE ASSOCIATION,
KNOWN AS CAL ANIMALS, WHICH IS
THE UMBRELLA ORGANIZATION FOR
NUMEROUS SHELTERS AND HUMANE
SOCIETIES ACROSS THE STATE, IS
HOSTING IS HOSTING THE FIRST
EVER CALIFORNIA ADOPT A PET DAY
ON SATURDAY, JUNE 1ST. HERE'S
THE GOAL. THE GOAL IS TO BE ABLE
TO HELP 2024 SHELTER PETS FIND
HOMES THIS SATURDAY, WITH MORE
THAN 150 ANIMAL WELFARE
ORGANIZATIONS PARTICIPATING FOR
FREE ADOPTIONS, ALL UNDERWRITTEN
BY GENEROUS ORGANIZATIONS AND
INDIVIDUALS. SO IF ANY OF YOU
HAVE A NEED TO BE ABLE TO BRING
A FOUR LEGGED FAMILY MEMBER INTO
YOUR HOME, HEADS UP, HEAD ON OUT
TO YOUR LOCAL SHELTER OR HUMANE
SOCIETY THIS WEEKEND, AND I'M
PROUD TO BE ABLE TO NOTE IN OUR
OFFICE. WE CURRENTLY HAVE 2828
RESCUED ANIMALS AT OUR
RESPECTIVE HOMES, INCLUDING
DOGS, CATS, PIGS, CHICKENS, AND
A FEW GOATS. SO WHETHER YOU'RE
AN ANIMAL LOVER OR AN ANIMAL
OWNER OR JUST A PARTY ANIMAL,
THIS IS A SMALL EFFORT THAT CAN
MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE FOR PETS
IN THE GOLDEN STATE. WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON SR 94. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? HEARING AND SEEING.
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON ITEM TEN ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DEL
AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. GLASER AYE. GONZALEZ.
AYE. GROVE AYE. HURTADO. AYE.
JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEMON
AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR MIN
AYE. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. AYE.
NILO. AYE. OCHOA BORG. PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO CIERTO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB. AYE
WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN ATKINS.
EGGMAN MENGIBAR. OCHOA RUBIO. IF
YOU WANT TO WAIT ON. YOU WANT TO
WAIT ON MENGIBAR? NO AYES 34.
NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES
NOW. MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. WE'RE GOING TO RECOGNIZE
SENATOR MCGUIRE. FOR PURPOSES OF
INTRODUCTION, SENATOR MCGUIRE,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. MR.
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. IN
COORDINATION WITH ADOPT THE PET
DAY, WE HAVE SOME WONDERFUL
ADVOCATES WHO DO SO MUCH FOR
ANIMALS ACROSS THE STATE IN THE
GALLERY WE HAVE JENNIFER
SCARLETT COMING FROM SENATOR
WEINER'S BACKYARD. SHE IS CEO OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO SPCA. WE HAVE
JILL TUCKER, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CAL ANIMALS. MELANIE SEDEK,
PRESIDENT OF CAL ANIMALS. AND OF
COURSE, BRITTANY MINCY,
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE ASPCA. UP TO MY
RIGHT. IF WE CAN PLEASE PUT OUR
PODS TOGETHER AND GIVE THEM A
WARM WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE AND THANK THEM FOR
THEIR INCREDIBLE WORK. THANK
YOU. WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. ALL RIGHT,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING BACK TO
FILE ITEM FOUR. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
. MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ. REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR MAY 20TH, 2024 THROUGH MAY
24TH, 2024 WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE SENATE CLERK.
NOW, MEMBERS, CONSIDERATION FOR
THE DAILY FILE. WE HAVE
UNFINISHED BUSINESS. WE HAVE ONE
ITEM. ITEM TWO. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 301 BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO. AN ACT
RELATING TO AIR POLLUTION.
SENATOR PORTANTINO. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT, AND MEMBERS, I'M
PRESENTING SB 301 ON CONCURRENCE
WITH THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS.
REMOVE THE REQUIREMENT FOR CARB
TO ALLOCATE A SPECIFIC DOLLAR
AMOUNT, SB 301 CREATES A NEW
PATHWAY TOWARD ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES THAT, WHEN FUNDED IN
BETTER ECONOMIC YEARS, WILL
ACCELERATE OUR PROGRESS TOWARD A
CLEANER FUTURE. AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY CALL ROLE ON FILE ITEM
TWO ALAN ALVARADO GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
ATKINS. BECKER BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ AYE. DALLI I. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN I.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ I. GROVE.
AYE. HURTADO I. JONES. AYE.
LAIRD I LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE
MENGIBAR I MEAN AYE. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN I NILO. AYE. OCHOA. BORG.
PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. SATO AYE.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK.
AYE SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN ATKINS.
BECKER. AYE. OCHOA RUBIO. AYES
36. NOES. ZERO. MEASURE PASSES
NOW. MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING TO
SENATE. THIRD READING. WE HAVE
TWO ITEMS. FIRST UP IS FILE ITEM
15. SENATOR WIENER, HE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 141 BY SENATOR WIENER
RELATIVE TO MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS MONTH. SENATOR WIENER,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES, I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SCR 141 TO
RECOGNIZE MAY 2024 AS NATIONAL
MENTAL HEALTH AWARENESS MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS MONTH ALLOWS US
TO CELEBRATE THE TREMENDOUS
STRIDES WE HAVE MADE IN
PROMOTING MENTAL HEALTH AND
INCREASING AWARENESS THAT
EFFECTIVE SERVICES AND SUPPORT
ARE AVAILABLE. WE MUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT TODAY, OUR
COUNTRY IS IN THE GRIPS OF A
RAPIDLY EVOLVING MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS. WE MUST PRIORITIZE
INCREASING ACCESS TO MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND WORK TO
CHANGE THE STIGMA AROUND MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT. AT OVER HALF
OF ADULTS IN THE US, MORE THAN
27 MILLION WHO HAVE A MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDER DO NOT RECEIVE
TREATMENT, AND THE PERCENTAGE OF
ADULTS WHO REPORT AN UNMET NEED
FOR TREATMENT HAS INCREASED
EVERY YEAR SINCE 2011. THESE
UNADDRESSED MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS ARE EXACERBATED WHEN
CRISES LIKE HOMELESSNESS,
POVERTY, UNEMPLOYMENT, LACK OF
SAFETY AND LOCAL ECONOMIC
CHALLENGES ARE TAKEN INTO
ACCOUNT. OUR COLLEAGUES, WE MUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CRISIS AMONG OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE, AS WELL. 20 Ã 2021
REPORT BY THE US SURGEON GENERAL
FOUND THAT NEARLY 1 IN 5 SCHOOL
AGED CHILDREN SUFFER FROM A
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDER AND
ALMOST HALF OF CHILDREN WITH A
TREATABLE MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION DID NOT RECEIVE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES IN THE LAST
YEAR. WE KNOW THAT ABOUT ONE
HALF OF MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS
MANIFEST BY AGE 14 AND 75% BY
THE AGE OF 24. THIS WIDENING GAP
HAS CONTRIBUTED TO A DEVASTATING
INCREASE IN YOUTH SUICIDE RATES,
SUICIDE BEING THE LEADING CAUSE
OF DEATH FOR TEENS AND YOUNG
ADULTS AGED 10 TO 34 ON YOUR
DESKS, COLLEAGUES, YOU'LL SEE A
LIME GREEN RIBBON AND CARD AND A
CARD FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES, THE SPONSOR OF THIS
RESOLUTION. I WANT TO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO WEAR YOUR RIBBON TODAY IN
HONOR OF NATIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
AWARENESS MONTH. THANK YOU TO
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES FOR YOUR
SPONSORSHIP AND TO THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL FOR MENTAL WELLBEING,
CALIFORNIA. MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS, FOR JOINTLY
SUPPORTING THE RESOLUTION,
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
OF COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AGENCIES AND THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS
AND PROFESSIONALS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM 15. ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY
AYE. ATKINS. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI. AYE DODD. AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE.
HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD.
AYE LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE
MENGIBAR. I'M IN. AYE. NEWMAN
AYE. NGUYEN. AYE. NILO AYE.
OCHOA. BOGH AYE. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO SEYARTO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE UMMAT. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. AYE AYES 37.
NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM 19 BY SENATOR CORTEZ.
HE IS PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 149 BY SENATOR CORTEZ
RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
REMEMBRANCE DAY. SENATOR CORTEZ,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, I RISE TO PRESENT SCR
149, WHICH DECLARES MAY 21ST AS
CALIFORNIA RECOMMERCE DAY
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF
SUPPORTING SUSTAINABLE PRACTICES
THAT BENEFIT BOTH THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THE RESIDENTS OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
RECOMMERCE REFERS TO THE BUYING,
SELLING, AND TRADING OF
PRE-OWNED GOODS BY ENCOURAGING
THE REUSE AND RECYCLING OF
PRODUCTS. RECOMMERCE FOSTER
SUSTAINABLE K¾T AND RESOURCE
EFFICIENCY. RECOMMERCE PLAYS A
SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN WASTE
REDUCTION IN 2022 ALONE,
RECOMMERCE CUT DOWN 73,000
METRIC TONS OF WASTE AND 1.6
MILLION METRIC TONS OF CARBON
EMISSIONS. ON TOP OF BEING
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY,
RECOMMERCE OFFERS CONSUMERS
AFFORDABLE ALTERNATIVES TO
PURCHASING BRAND NEW ITEMS IN
HONOR OF CALIFORNIA RECOMMERCE
DAY, I ENCOURAGE ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO SUPPORT
ACTIVITIES THAT CELEBRATE
RECOMMERCE, INCLUDING PURCHASING
PRE-OWNED GOODS, DONATING ITEMS
FOR REUSE, AND ADVOCATING FOR
POLICIES THAT PROMOTE
SUSTAINABILITY AND RESOURCE
CONSERVATION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING. SEEING
NONE. MEMBERS. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO APPLYING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL TO FILE
ITEM 19? HEARING AND SEEING NONE
AYES 37. NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW MEMBERS, WE'RE
MOVING ON TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. NOW IS THE TIME
FOR ANY COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT.
THANK YOU. CORTEZ. YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. YES MR. PRESIDENT,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WILL
CONVENE IN ROOM 1200. IMMEDIATE
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS MEETING. THANK YOU.
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WILL
MEET IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN ROOM 1200IN
THE SWING SPACE. NOW MEMBERS,
NOW IS THE TIME FOR MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. WE'RE RETURNING TO
THAT PORTION. FIRST UP IS
SENATOR BLAKESPEAR FOR ADJOURN
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU, PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES. IT'S MY HONOR TO
ADJOURN THE SENATE IN MEMORY OF
JAMES H. FALLON. A DISTINGUISHED
NEUROANATOMY EXPERT AND
PROFESSOR OF PSYCHIATRY AND
HUMAN BEHAVIOR. JIM'S CAREER AT
UC IRVINE SPANNED OVER 35 YEARS.
THE UNIQUE CHARACTERISTICS OF
HIS OWN BRAIN BROUGHT HIM
UNEXPECTED FAME AND RESULTED IN
BREAKTHROUGH RESEARCH. HIS BRAIN
LED HIM TO COIN THE TERM
PRO-SOCIAL PSYCHOPATH. PROFESSOR
FALLON DIED AT THE AGE OF 76 ON
NOVEMBER 20TH, 2023. HE IS
SURVIVED BY DIANE, HIS WIFE OF
OVER 54 YEARS, TWO DAUGHTERS, A
SON AND MULTIPLE GRANDCHILDREN,
AND AN INFANT GREAT GRANDSON. HE
ALSO HAD A LASTING IMPACT ON
MANY OTHERS, INCLUDING PHD
STUDENTS AND POSTDOCTORAL
FELLOWS, AND APPROXIMATELY 3000
MEDICAL STUDENTS AND RESIDENTS
WHO RECEIVED TRAINING IN
NEUROSCIENCE FROM HIM. THESE
STUDENTS APPRECIATED HIS
COLORFUL AND ENTERTAINING
LECTURES, AND IN RETURN HONORED
HIM WITH SEVERAL STUDENT DRIVEN
AWARDS. JIM EARNED HIS DEGREES
FROM THE UNIVERSITIES IN
VERMONT, NEW YORK, AND CHICAGO,
BUT HE FOUND HIS ACADEMIC HOME
AT UC IRVINE, WHERE HE SERVED AS
A POPULAR PROFESSOR IN THE
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE. HE CHAIRED
THE UCI FACULTY AND ACADEMIC
SENATE AND THE UCI COLLEGE OF
MEDICINE FACULTY, AND HE
COMPLETED HIS CAREER AS EMERITUS
PROFESSOR OF ANATOMY AND
NEUROBIOLOGY. HE WAS A LEADER IN
HIS FIELD WITH EXTENSIVE
KNOWLEDGE OF THE PATHWAYS OF THE
BRAIN. HE WAS THE FIRST TO
DEMONSTRATE THE LARGE SCALE
PRESENCE OF STEM CELLS IN THE
INJURED ADULT BRAIN. HIS
RESEARCH ENCOMPASSES
SCHIZOPHRENIA, PARKINSON'S
DISEASE, ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE,
ADDICTION, MENTAL HEALTH,
LANGUAGE DISORDERS, AND MAGNETIC
RESONANCE IMAGING. HIS WORK ALSO
DELVED INTO THE REALMS OF
PERSONALITY, INTELLIGENCE,
CONSCIOUSNESS, ANESTHESIA,
SLEEP, EMOTIONAL MEMORY, AND THE
MODELING OF NEURAL CIRCUITS. HE
AUTHORED OVER 300 PAPERS IN
BOOKS. JIM SERVED ON A WIDE
VARIETY OF BOOKS OF BOARDS AND
COMMITTEES, INCLUDING THE
AMERICAN LAND FORCES INSTITUTE.
THROUGH HIS WORK AS AN ADVISOR
TO THE PENTAGON AND ON THE
VATICAN ARTS AND TECHNOLOGY
COUNCIL, HIS ACADEMIC CAREER WAS
ILLUSTRIOUS BY ANY MEASURE, BUT
HE FOUND EXTRAORDINARY FAME
THROUGH AN ANOMALY THAT HE
SERENDIPITY HE DISCOVERED DURING
A RESEARCH PROJECT THAT FOREVER
CHANGED HIS LIFE. IN 2005, WHILE
RESEARCHING ALZHEIMER'S, HE USED
BRAIN SCANS OF HIS HEALTHY
FAMILY MEMBERS AS A CONTROL
WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY REVIEWING
THE MRIS OF MURDEROUS
PSYCHOPATHS FOR ANOTHER PROJECT.
THE RESULTS SEEMED TO INDICATE
THAT ONE OF THE KILLER'S SCANS
HAD BEEN MISTAKENLY SHUFFLED
INTO THE BATCH WITH HIS OWN
FAMILY SCANS, BUT AS IT TURNED
OUT, NO MISTAKE HAD BEEN MADE.
THE BRAIN SCAN THAT MIRRORED
THOSE OF THE PSYCHOPATHIC
MURDERERS WAS, IN FACT, HIS VERY
OWN BRAIN. THIS PROMPTED JIM TO
DELVE INTO HIS FAMILY TREE AND
SPEAK WITH EXPERTS, COLLEAGUES,
RELATIVES AND FRIENDS.
ULTIMATELY, HIS RESEARCH LED HIM
TO CATEGORIZE HIMSELF AS A
PRO-SOCIAL PSYCHOPATH. HIS
STUDIES LED TO A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF PSYCHOPATHS,
SOCIOPATHS, AND THE DIRECT
IMPACT THAT PREADOLESCENT TRAUMA
HAS ON THOSE WITH PSYCHOPATHIC
BRAINS AND THEIR BEHAVIOR. JIM
WROTE ABOUT HIS RESEARCH AND
FINDINGS IN THE PERSONAL, VERY
PERSONAL BOOK, THE SOCIOPATHIC
SORRY, THE PSYCHOPATH INSIDE A
NEUROSCIENTIST PERSONAL JOURNEY
INTO THE DARK SIDE OF THE BRAIN,
WHICH WAS AN AMAZON BESTSELLER
AND AVAILABLE IN EIGHT
LANGUAGES. HIS RESEARCH REVEALED
THAT THE NURTURING SUPPORT HE
EXPERIENCED AS A CHILD AND HIS
HAPPY, STABLE ADULT LIFE ENABLED
HIM TO BE HEALTHY, STABLE,
POSITIVE AND PRODUCTIVE INSTEAD
OF A MURDEROUS PSYCHOPATH.
GROWING UP, JIM ENJOYED CLOSE
AND LOVING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
HIS LARGE, IMMEDIATE, AND
EXTENDED ITALIAN AMERICAN
FAMILY. HE AND HIS FUTURE WIFE,
DIANE, MET AT AGE 12. HE
FULFILLED HIS DREAM OF BECOMING
A SCIENTIST, AND HE FLOURISHED
DURING A LONG AND SUCCESSFUL
ACADEMIC CAREER. JIM APPEARED IN
OVER 370 NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL TV AND RADIO
SPECIALS. SPEAKING ON WAR,
DICTATORSHIPS, PSYCHOPATHIC
BEHAVIOR, MURDER, VIOLENCE AND
TERRORISM, AS WELL AS THE FUTURE
OF BIOTECHNOLOGY AND
MODIFICATION OF BEHAVIOR. IN
2009, HE APPEARED AS HIMSELF ON
THE CBS CRIME DRAMA CRIMINAL
MINDS, WHICH EXPLORED HIS THEORY
OF TRANSGENERATIONAL VIOLENCE IN
AREAS OF THE WORLD THAT
EXPERIENCE CONTINUOUS BOUTS OF
TERRORISM, WAR, AND VIOLENCE.
JIM'S LIFE IS AN INCREDIBLE
STORY OF A TALENTED SCIENTIST
WHO, THROUGH AN UNEXPECTED AND
SHOCKING PERSONAL DISCOVERY,
EXPANDED THE FORMIDABLE RESEARCH
OF HIS ACADEMIC CAREER TO
INCLUDE TRANSFORMATIVE STUDIES
IN HUMAN BEHAVIOR. JIM WILL
ALWAYS BE REMEMBERED FOR HIS
WIT, LAUGHTER, OUTSIZED
PERSONALITY, INTELLECT, AND
GENEROSITY OF SPIRIT BY HIS
FAMILY, FRIENDS, COLLEAGUES,
STUDENTS, AND THE MANY OTHERS
THAT HE TOUCHED WITH HIS
PRESENCE AND RESEARCH. WITH
THAT, I ASK THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE TO ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ON
THIS AIM, SENATOR. MEN THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES,
I WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM ENCINITAS FOR, SUMMING UP
THE CAREER OF A REALLY
REMARKABLE ACADEMIC CITIZEN. I
RISE ALSO TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF JIM FALLON, A PROFESSOR AND
FORMER COLLEAGUE OF MINE AT UC
IRVINE, MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ENCINITAS LAID OUT WHAT IS TRULY
A REMARKABLE ACADEMIC CAREER, HE
IS WRITING CELEBRATED TED TALK,
SEVERAL HUNDRED APPEARANCES ON
NATIONAL INTERNATIONAL TV, THE
BOOKS, ALL OF THAT, REACHED
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE, HE WAS A
BRILLIANT AND REMARKABLE
PROFESSOR. BUT I REALLY JUST
WANT TO NOTE WHAT A GOOD
ACADEMIC CITIZEN HE WAS. SOMEONE
WITH HIS ACCOLADES, SOMEONE WITH
HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS, DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE ENGAGED IN THE
ACADEMIC COMMUNITY. CERTAINLY,
THERE ARE MANY EXAMPLES OF
PROFESSORS WITH HIS FAME WHO
DON'T ENGAGE. BUT HE WAS
REMEMBERED FOR ALSO BEING A
WONDERFUL ACADEMIC CITIZEN, HE
WAS VOTED TEACHER OF THE YEAR
SEVERAL TIMES WITHIN THE SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA, IRVINE, WAS
PRESIDENT OF THE FACULTY AND
ACADEMIC SENATE. HE WAS SOMEONE
WHO GAVE TO OUR COMMUNITY OVER
AND OVER. AND SO HIS LOSS WAS A
HUGE ONE FOR OUR COMMUNITY. SO I
JOINED MY COLLEAGUE FROM
ENCINITAS IN ASKING THE SENATE
TO JOIN ME TODAY IN OFFERING OUR
MOST SINCERE CONDOLENCES TO HIS
WIFE, DIANE, AND THEIR SONS AND
DAUGHTERS, FAMILY MEMBERS,
FRIENDS, COLLEAGUES AND
STUDENTS, AND ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE
EXTEND OUR MOST SINCERE
CONDOLENCES TO THE FALLON FAMILY
AND ASK THAT YOU BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO IT CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. NEXT UP IS SENATOR
MEN. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES. I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF SUN
XIAOGANG, KNOWN AS DON SUN. DON
SERVED AS PRESIDENT OF THE BAY
AREA CHAPTER OF APAPA AND WAS
THE DIRECTOR OF THE ASIAN
AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER FUND
AS WELL AS THE DEVELOPMENT CHAIR
FOR ANDREW YANG'S HUMANITY
FORWARD MOVEMENT. IN 2020. HE
PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE ASIAN
AMERICANS FOR GOOD GOVERNMENT
PAC AND AT THE TIME OF HIS
DEATH, DON WAS THE CEO OF THE
CHINESE AMERICAN YOUTH COMMUNITY
LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE. DON WAS A
DEEPLY DEVOTED COMMUNITY LEADER
AND ORGANIZER WHO WAS DEEPLY
BELOVED IN THE BAY AREA AAPI
COMMUNITY AND WAS PASSIONATE
ABOUT THE CAUSE OF HAVING MORE
ASIAN AMERICAN REPRESENTATION IN
POLITICS. THIS WAS ALSO A DEEPLY
HUMBLE MAN WHO, DESPITE HIS MANY
ACCOMPLISHMENTS IN LIFE, LIVED A
VERY SIMPLE LIFE, LIVING IN A
SMALL COTTAGE IN A RECREATION
CENTER IN LOS GATOS. BEGINNING
AROUND THE TIME OF THE PANDEMIC,
HE SPENT HIS TIME AND ENERGY
TRYING TO EMPOWER AND LIFT UP
THE AAPI COMMUNITY, ESPECIALLY
YOUNG PEOPLE. I SAW HIM MOST
RECENTLY LAST YEAR IN AN EVENT
HE HAD PUT TOGETHER FOR YOUNG
WOMEN AND GIRLS INTERESTED IN
POLITICS. HE ALWAYS TRIED TO
INCLUDE YOUNG PEOPLE IN HIS
EVENTS AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY
HAD A ROLE AND WERE EXPLICITLY
RECOGNIZED, N N WAS ALSO
INCREDIBLY GENEROUS, NOT JUST
WITH HIS MONEY AND TIME, BUT
ALSO IN EVERY OTHER WAY. ONE
TIME I STAYED OVER IN THE BAY
AREA AND I HAD A 7:30 A.M.
FLIGHT BACK HOME AFTER ONE OF
HIS EVENTS, AND HE INSISTED ON
GETTING UP AT 6 A.M. AND DRIVING
ME PERSONALLY TO THE AIRPORT.
THAT WAS JUST THE TYPE OF PERSON
HE WAS SO GENEROUS AND GIVING.
HIS DEDICATION TO SUPPORTING
AAPI LEADERS WAS UNMATCHED, AND
HE TRULY WANTED TO HELP EVERYONE
HE COULD. HE PASSED ON MARCH
13TH AFTER A PROLONGED BATTLE
WITH CANCER. HIS FAMILY WAS WITH
HIM AT THE END, AND HIS LOSS
LEAVES A HUGE HOLE IN OUR HEARTS
AND IN OUR COMMUNITY. I ASK THE
SENATE TO JOIN ME TODAY IN
OFFERING OUR MOST SINCERE
CONDOLENCES TO HIS SON'S FAMILY
MEMBERS, FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES
AND ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR BECKER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, TO THE SENATOR FROM
IRVINE FOR THESE KIND WORDS,
DON, LIVED IN MY DISTRICT. HE
HAD SOME SHARED EXPERIENCES FROM
PHILADELPHIA, WHERE HE EARNED
HIS MASTER'S DEGREE IN ECONOMICS
FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA AND, AND AS
MENTIONED, HIS ASIAN AMERICAN
FORWARD PAC BECAME ONE OF THE
MOST INFLUENTIAL CAMPAIGN
ORGANIZATIONS NATIONWIDE. BUT HE
NEVER LOST CONNECTION TO THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY OR THE
DEDICATION TO SERVICE AND
EDUCATION THAT MADE HIM SO
INSPIRING. HE WAS A 16 YEAR
BOARD MEMBER OF THE ROTARY CLUB
OF CUPERTINO, AND HE ADDRESSED
SOCIAL ISSUES WORLDWIDE WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY TACKLING PROBLEMS
IN OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY. IN 2017,
HE WAS RECOGNIZED ASIAN
COMMUNITY LEADER AWARD BY
CONGRESSMAN RO KHANNA, AND THIS
AWARD ONLY FURTHER ELEVATED DON
SON'S STANDING AS A VOICE FOR
CHANGE IN THE COMMUNITY. AFTER
HE PASSED, ONE OF OUR FRIENDS
SAID SOMETHING THAT REALLY
RESONATED WITH ME. DON WAS
ALWAYS PURSUING THE SPIRIT OF
LIFE. HE NEVER LOST SENSE OF HIS
OPTIMISM ABOUT THIS COUNTRY AND
ITS FUTURE, AND THIS ABILITY TO
SEE THE BEST IN EVERYONE AND
WILLINGNESS TO SHARE HIS TIME,
ENERGY AND INSIGHT IS SOMETHING
WE ALL SHOULD STRIVE FOR. SO I
JOIN MY COLLEAGUE FROM IRVINE IN
ASKING THE SENATE TO ADJOURN IN
HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WE EXTEND OUR MOST SINCERE
CONDOLENCES TO HIS FAMILY AND
ASK THAT YOU BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. NEXT UP IS SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I ASK THAT
WE RISE TO ADJOURN THE SENATE IN
MEMORY OF PEGGY. MORE AND HER
WIFE, HOPE WOULD. PEGGY WAS A
DEAR FRIEND AND A FIERCE
ADVOCATE FOR LGBTQ RIGHTS,
DEMOCRACY, EQUITY AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE. A LONGTIME RESIDENT OF
OAKLAND, PEGGY AND HER BELOVED
WIFE AND HER BUSINESS PARTNER,
HOPE WOOD WERE KILLED TRAGICALLY
ON MAY 10TH IN A CAR ACCIDENT IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY. THE CRASH TOOK
THE LIVES OF FOUR PEOPLE PEGGY
HAD JUST RECENTLY CELEBRATED HER
60TH BIRTHDAY. THEY WERE ON
THEIR WAY BACK FROM A CONCERT.
PEGGY AND HOPE FIRST MET IN
2008. THEY WERE FIELD ORGANIZERS
ON BARACK OBAMA'S SUCCESSFUL
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN. IN 2012,
FOR BARACK'S REELECTION
CAMPAIGN, PEGGY SERVED AS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN
DIRECTOR FOR THAT REELECTION,
AND SHE HELD THAT SAME POSITION
STATE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN
OF HILLARY CLINTON IN 2016. NOW
BACK TO PEGGY AND HOPE. WHILE
THEY WERE BEING FIELD ORGANIZERS
FOR PRESIDENT OBAMA, WHO WAS NOT
YET PRESIDENT, THIS IS IN 2008.
THEY WERE ALSO WORKING ON THE
NO. ON PROP EIGHT CAMPAIGN, AND
THAT'S WHEN I FIRST GOT TO KNOW
THEM, BECAUSE I WAS RUNNING FOR
THE ASSEMBLY. AND IN THOSE DAYS
BEFORE WE HAD THE TOP TWO
PRIMARY, I HAD, IN EFFECT WON
THE PRIMARY. AND EVEN THOUGH I
WAS ON THE BALLOT IN NOVEMBER,
THAT CAMPAIGN PERIOD, BETWEEN
JUNE AND NOVEMBER WAS PRETTY
MUCH, I DIDN'T REALLY HAVE TO DO
MUCH, BUT I STILL HAD
HEADQUARTERS, SO I TURNED MY
HEADQUARTERS AND MY VOLUNTEERS
AND MY PHONES AND SUCH OVER TO
THE NO ON EIGHT CAMPAIGN, AND
PEGGY AND HOPE WERE THERE QUITE
FREQUENTLY, UNFORTUNATELY, AS WE
ALL KNOW, THAT BALLOT MEASURE
PASSED. AND THEN WHILE, PROP
EIGHT WAS CHALLENGED IN COURT,
GAY MARRIAGE WAS ILLEGAL IN
CALIFORNIA FOR A GOOD NUMBER OF
YEARS. SO IT WASN'T UNTIL 2013
THAT PEGGY AND HOPE WERE MARRIED
AT OAKLAND'S LAKE MERRITT. AND
THEY DID THAT AFTER THE SUPREME
COURT STRUCK DOWN THE FEDERAL
DOMA ACT. SO IT WASN'T THE
SUPREME COURT DECISION THAT MADE
GAY MARRIAGE LEGAL ACROSS THE
WHOLE COUNTRY. BUT WHEN THEY BUT
THAT DECISION IN 2013 THAT
STRUCK DOWN DOMA. OVER THE
YEARS, PEGGY WAS KNOWN FOR HER
TIRELESS EFFORTS WORKING FOR
POLITICAL LEADERS FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS CAMPAIGNS. IN 2014, SHE
WAS THE MANAGER FOR MAYOR FOR
LIBBY SCHAAF'S SUCCESSFUL
CAMPAIGN FOR OAKLAND MAYOR. SHE
WENT ON TO WORK AS A SENIOR
ADVISOR FOR LIBBY SCHAAF IN THE
MAYOR'S OFFICE, AND IN 2018,
PEGGY COORDINATED CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY DIANA
BECTON, WINNING CAMPAIGN, WHICH
MADE BECTON THE VERY FIRST WOMAN
AND FIRST BLACK DA FOR CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY. IN 2019, PEGGY
WORKED FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AS A TRAINING
DIRECTOR. THE FOLLOWING YEAR,
SHE AND HOPE LAUNCHED THEIR OWN
POLITICAL CONSULTING FIRM, WHICH
THEY NAMED HOPE ACTION CHANGE.
IN RECENT YEARS, THEY SPLIT
THEIR TIME BETWEEN OAKLAND AND
SAN DIEGO BECAUSE SAN DIEGO WAS
WHERE HOPE'S FAMILY LIVED, SO
PEGGY WAS WELL KNOWN IN THE EAST
BAY FOR ALL OF THOSE REASONS
THAT I DESCRIBED, BUT ALSO FOR
CO-FOUNDING SISTER'S STEPPING IN
PRIDE, A QUEER WOMEN'S MARCH
THAT WAS HELD IN OAKLAND
THROUGHOUT THE 2000, AND AT HER
MEMORIAL AT LAKE MERRITT ON MAY
12TH. THERE WERE SEVERAL
MOURNERS WHO WERE THERE WEARING
SISTER'S STEP AND T SHIRTS IN
HER HONOR. SHE HAD AN EBULLIENT
SMILE. SHE HAD AN EASY MANNER.
SHE KNEW EVERYONE ONE, BUT SHE
WAS PARTICULARLY COMMITTED TO
SUPPORTING WOMEN IN COLOR. OUR
MUTUAL FRIEND, BART, BOARD
DIRECTOR LATEEFAH SIMON, CALLED
PEGGY A FRIEND, AN ACTIVIST AND
ONE OF THE BEST ORGANIZERS THAT
SHE KNEW, AND FORMER OAKLAND
MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF SAID THAT
WHENEVER SHE WALKED WITH PEGGY,
IT WOULD TAKE MUCH EXTRA TIME
BECAUSE WHEREVER THEY WENT,
PEOPLE WOULD STOP AND KNOW
PEGGY. THEY KNEW PEGGY BETTER
THAN THE MAYOR, BUT LIBBY ADDED
THAT PEGGY WAS SOMEONE WHO
BELIEVED EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE A
VOICE IN GOVERNMENT. SHE NEVER
GAVE UP ON THE BEAUTIFUL ESSENCE
OF DEMOCRACY, EVEN WHEN IT GAVE
UP ON HER. THE BEAUTIFUL ESSENCE
OF PEGGY MOORE WILL NEVER BE
FORGOTTEN. AND I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY AND IN HER
WIFE, HOPE WOOD'S MEMORY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES TO THE LOSS OF AN
AMAZING INDIVIDUAL. AND WE ASK
THAT YOU BRING HER NAME FORWARD
SO SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. IF THERE'S NO
OTHER BUSINESS. SENATOR MCGUIRE,
THE DUST IS CLEAR. MR.
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE NEXT FLOOR SESSION IS
SCHEDULED FOR THURSDAY, MAY 30TH
AT 9 A.M. ENJOY THE SHORT WEEK.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL 3:30 P.M, AT WHICH TIME AN
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE.
WE'LL RECONVENE THURSDAY, MAY
30TH, 2024 AT 9 A.M.